i know or no men i know are down with
trans women competing against biological
women the majority of us men don't want
this why are women giving away their
sport
why why
why do women do that like we
you guys are doing
yeah
but it's like we were saying earlier is
like that empathy and we don't and we
don't want to be the person to speak up
yeah because it's not it's not like i
don't think it's natural to women to
like go into conflict i just think men
are better at it
yeah it's like we're saying like
we
this dang
person made a good point
and like essentially like if it keeps
going if we keep making this exception
there's going to be
more and more trans women athletes that
are going to come out and play the
sports and it's going to be more and
more to where there's less and less
biological women that have those
opportunities to play and scholarships
are going to be taken
um
spots on proteins are going to be taken
because
i mean
naturally to the natural eye if you look
on a piece of paper you don't know if a
person is a trans woman or a biological
man you see the skill sales skill set
blah blah blah and then you see oh
they're six six and you have a 511
person and the skill set is the same i'm
gonna pick the sixth sixth person and
then you find out as a trans woman
you're just like
okay well they're six six so it's okay
it's like
there's going
there
there will come a point where it's just
we won't have a shot anymore
and there's nothing
physically nothing we can do about it to
train ourselves to be able to
compete with men yeah
yeah and it's like and that's so sad
like that makes my like i love
people people think i don't because i
say men are better than women but i love
women's sports like i i don't think i
would be who and where i am today if i
didn't have sports exactly like i
wouldn't even go as far as to say like
it it like saved me out of like rough
situation i think a lot of athletes
would like say that
and like the thought of just having like
these guys like
like dressed as women kicking our asses
yeah it would
it would suck but like
like
i think they they like people should
really consider like
making another
another
another league or just like yeah another
league and it'd just be
the trans league and
that's the fairest
way to do it yeah the first way to do it
yeah like
you can
try you can try like trans from a man to
a woman but
like as we've stated
biologically you're still
a man underneath like you can't identify
as a woman we'll all identify like we'll
all say you are yeah
like you're still going to be better
than us physically like physically so
it's only fair for them to have their
own league if they want to be identified
as a woman yeah yeah
and essentially
i don't know how
like
money works with schools and where they
get it from but i i would think that
you'd be able to get more money if you
have
trans athletes because you would want to
schools may want to promote that more
it's schools love promoting the best
things out there and so you'd be able to
get more grants from people who
maybe are trans uh men or women that
they don't know you're donating and
i think it it'd be something to consider
no i would agree actually i would be
fine with a third league or even a
league where like men and women can
compete against each other if they want
to
but it's also back to like we i think
you said this on one episode where
a lot of like you don't know that
they're trans going in
and so there was a fighter that did this
and this fighter was just kicking
women's ass and then it came out that
they were trans i don't know i i can't
say the name i don't even know real
people's names
yeah and that'd be cool the trans
olympics but
i just oh my gosh
okay next next 50